happy birthday you're not special you
can't know
happy wares birthday everybody this is
Michael Kosta thank you for listening to
the worst birthday podcast and the all
things comedy Network or on iTunes or
stitcher or SoundCloud thank you very
much
we've had some great episodes and this
is not an exception this week we have
the wonderful Chris Fairbanks very funny
comedian with a very funny real organic
works birthday story it's probably not
organic if you have to say it's organic
it's supposed to feel organic but this
is a great worst birthday please check
out Chris Fairbanks and his show on
truTV called almost genius we talked
about that in the beginning and I've
known Chris forever he's a fantastic
stand-up let's get through some office
stuff I have plenty of live dates on
Michael Kosta calm I will be an Erie
Pennsylvania November 10 through 12 st.
Louis funnybone November 17 through 20
I'll be in Washington DC for New Year's
Eve I'll be in Vancouver in January
Cleveland Winnipeg Chattanooga I'm very
lucky that I get to to around the world
and do stand-up comedy but I'm even
luckier if podcast listeners come out to
the show so check out my live the shows
posted on Michael Kosta calm if you're
gonna do some Amazon shopping which I
know we all are go to worst birthday
calm first click on the amazon banner
takes you right back to amazon and now
you some shopping and the worst birthday
podcast gets a four percent kickback
which is nothing but it helps us run the
show it pays for editing which we very
rarely do but sometimes it pays for web
hosting it pays for gas blah blah blah
I'm not making tons of money I'm making
no money but if you go to Amazon through
worst birthday com it can help us out I
also now have a store available on my
web page Michael Kosta calm click store
you can pre-order your first male
president t-shirt I'm anticipating
Hillary Clinton is going to win this
thing and I'm anticipating tons of first
female president t-shirts so I'm making
a t-shirt they're being ordered and
shipped right now already in the mail
called the first male president and
picture George Washington okay I support
Hillary Clinton but I also support
George Washington if you're gonna tweet
use and use the hashtag worst bday pod
and tweet to us
tweet to me at Michael Kosta tweet to
Chris Fairbanks and let us know you
enjoy the podcast we very much
appreciate that if you leave a rating
and a review on iTunes make sure you
leave your handle in there I'll send you
a tweet I'll mention you on the podcast
we really appreciate the positive
feedback it's I know everyone's asking
you for feedback these days but it just
helps it helps us get showcased more
whatever the [ __ ] algorithm is if you
get a lot of ratings and reviews it
showcases you more so if you like the
podcast please do that thank you very
very much every Thursday we have a new
worst birthday and don't forget go -
worst birthday com go to Michael Kosta
calm click the shop if you want to buy a
first male t-shirt for the day that
Hillary Clinton is elected president I
think it's going to happen you can rock
that the next day they're great t-shirts
made in America I love you guys man
please enjoy the whisk this worst
birthday we'll see on the other end
thanks again enjoy Chris Fairbanks happy
worst birthday you guys
so almost genius with with April
Richardson and you Chris Fairbanks Chris
Fairbanks is here hi hi there good job
thank you uh we're waiting right now to
see if that comes back for a second
season but yesterday describe what you
were just telling me this person tweets
you tweets to you I was on my way it was
late I was going to Dinosaur Jr a band I
like and I like Dinosaur Jr it's the bat
it was a who else loves Dinosaur Jr
comedian [ __ ] who the [ __ ] is it I mean
have you played some of the songs people
be like oh I've always liked but
somebody goes nuts over Dinosaur Jr
who's a comic friend we'll have to all
have to do it in the out rowers yep okay
you're going to see dinosaur junk and
then and as I Drive I always glance down
at my phone like all this I got a
someone said hey in a tweet if you uh if
you get tired of America after Trump
wins come up here and play with us
mmm that said hashtag almost genius and
I'm like that's weird that's the name of
my show TV show so I looked at his
Twitter his the picture was our the logo
we used for the pilot now the new logo
after the pilot right so this person
pulled the logo right I thought and then
there was clips of a show that's just
like ours except everyone saying sorry
in a boot which you can read you can
which you can read a difference they do
the same show there except without hosts
without my position it's just the goof
on videos and they they shot it years
ago and it was sold to them by sold to
them by the production company to
another production company by the one
that I that makes money which is which
is what production
they're called meetinghouse they made
all they made world's dumbest so which
which was untrue mm-hm you did some
world's dumbest how many world's dumbest
did you do I did that for a few years
okay you did a lot of those and I feel
like whenever i watch world's dumbest
record breakers criminals i see you in
some some fun outfit and if it wasn't me
I was the one sitting across from them
everything what have you where'd it like
this yes and pretending to laugh there
is no laughter in the back
I hate when you do those panels or not
panel shows like two camera shows
they're always like that was great but
what if you said it in an ace to say it
exactly how you have to say I'm the guy
you know the guy that does that so so so
meetinghouse mm-hmm used the logo for
the Canadian show and that their logo
for your pilot right thinking if this
thing gets picked up will change the
logo I yeah I guess yeah and it does our
logo is a little hipper yeah you know
well it's United States in Canada
Thanks I love Canada I love Canadians
but music include the things that it's
always a few years behind I 10 years I
always laugh when you land in Canada and
you hear the songs over the restaurants
and it's always like it's just a tad
cheese dip it's Nellie is on the radio
and everyone caller is popped yes
exactly right but they're good people
and I'd love to live there and oh I live
among them they are great people with a
very high-quality life mm-hmm British
Columbia how can you beat BC you just
stand in line for a hip surgery
yeah that's me it's true sign a piece of
paper I remember going to Vancouver one
time and I was walking or something and
I just saw lineups on the street
Pete there's just lot there was people
lining up in order mm-hmm and I was like
what the [ __ ] is this why are there just
people lined up in this guy very kind
Canadian goes well the bus the bus will
be here and so we just line up and I'm
like god this is so single file single
file they're waiting for the bus to in
the bus and like you don't we'll pre
line up in the States you all stand in a
[ __ ] bunch and then when the you know
you run in it's like this is just great
what a high quality of life in Calgary
they have a train system that's it's the
honor system they don't have like thugs
or I mean security guards checking
everyone for everyone pays in everyone
pays everyone pays right people make fun
of me here because because la train I
overpay because I want to like I want
them to see some revenue yeah yeah there
I was on a show on Fox Sports 1 three or
four years ago called crowd goes wild
there was a sports show there was a show
in New Zealand called the crowd goes
mmm-hmm we would get their tweets oh I
still get the crowd goes well to his but
it was like you're almost genius thing
it was exactly the same except they
already owned the crowd goes wild so we
were crowd goes well then we still it
seems like a very funny show it's weird
yeah that happened a few old TV which
was a fox sports yes it was they they
cancelled it entirely and turned it to
MMA stuff here so we were out of a job I
took things off the wall I'll grab
clothes but they still in Portugal
there's always been truTV and apparently
I did a comedy special on fuel
apparently they play it there you you
did a comedy I got it okay wiggle
important point it could be worse yeah
who cares that'd be great if you became
like [ __ ] there you know great
personality yeah yeah I guess they speak
English there I guess I was I think they
dubbed I think we have a fun me and you
have a fun Hollywood relationship
because well I knew you prior to but
when we when we reunited but we became
closer when I at the comments section at
E and you were working as the crowd what
woody could warm up yeah it's warm I
mean I hate to even say that because
sometimes that has a negative
connotation but you know I does with me
it does with you yeah I would get good
laughs at the show and then we we would
stop for a second and I would hear these
enormous laughs from the corner and I'd
be like where the [ __ ] were those laughs
when I was doing stuff that six writers
wrote great writers by the way they were
great they're great writers very
wonderful people Sean Tom Sean Thomas
and Jeannette Tim Mike Henry Greg Heller
Daniel Koenig and all Daniel Kotick um
but and then literally within two weeks
you were warming up the audience for my
show my show was over and you had your
own show I'm not saying the war I'm
heading to do with the show but it
literally was like this hey everyone
this how Hollywood works it was you
going in you're going out you're in
you're out right right right yes there
was an overlap there where I'm like well
I'm gonna keep doing this warm-up okay I
did a show after yours but it it got
canceled also which one was Annie
Letterman and Julianne oh the the
you've got issues with it yeah yeah you
enjoy doing warm-up I did I mean there
was times where I did but once I
realized it was less about telling jokes
and more about hey you guys come on
you know don't you know that you are
let's laugh here here's some candy yeah
that the wrangling there what what would
be is he hasn't what would be your ideal
situation almost almost genius yeah it
was great I don't fun right haven't have
a show a show more like the one you had
that's just sort of like a rubbing it in
ya know what I really liked the setup
you had I mean you had a UNM - I was
also by myself set it was nice but but
it must be fun and also terrible having
a partner because you work together so
much no it was April's great yeah her
she's awesome
it was the she was the reason when I
wasn't looking forward to it because the
you know there was a joke I didn't like
right or whatever it didn't want to wake
up early whatever she was always made it
fun that's so that was the good part and
do you guys go on the road sometimes
together under stand up yeah yeah we've
done that as well done some gigs okay
yeah um when is your birthday it is on
the February February the 5th February
the 5th how is that as a date it's not
bad I mean it's uh it's usually cold I
mean in Montana it was cold that's where
you're from originally yeah yeah which I
believe the state population is is it
like under a million people yes bitin
terribly and it's the fourth largest
state so that's a lot of land yeah land
mass a lot of gaps in between humans Wow
yeah and as the speed limit still
Prudence equally every person there has
at least 20 feet surrounding that's the
one thing used to not have a speed limit
yeah no now it is just 75 that's
[ __ ] yeah because people rather
before that when there was a speed limit
it was a $5 ticket
I remember seeing a comic when I was a
kid on TV said here's a 20 I'm gonna
speed through the turquoise I think it
was a pre Larry the Cable Guy Dan
Whitney it was but they but then when
they it was reasonable and prudent if
you did get a ticket it was like a
reckless driving
hundreds of dollars so people are like
yeah this isn't that cool it's not the
Autobahn now we just don't know Rast we
can go okay the speed limit back and
they're like oh okay
see I never would have thought that's
what happened so people wanted this be
Montanans mm-hmm that we called it yeah
yeah Montanans wanted the speed limit
and it's a still low fine if you I don't
know I think you're probably compared to
hear everything I mean if you're from
out of state and you are at a parking
meter and don't put money in it they'd
leave a little note instead of a ticket
that says welcome to town here's a
cookin on the back there's a coupon I
think Jimmy does it Sajjad sir Domino's
buddy how was growing up did you grow up
there yeah how has that affected your
comedy or influence your comedy would
you say have you answered this question
100 times no it's uh I don't know I'm
lucky that I got into it because sure
oddly my dad sort of had a comedy career
he was a radio guy and he would sell
jokes ceramics in the bay are we I was
born in Monterey and he did a video
there okay had a couple kids and he is
like well I gotta get a real job right
you know something I would maybe think
about if I skip out a cup of pups
so we went back to Montana and and yeah
he got like a government got an
appraisal job yeah and was he always
like the Entertainer of the home he's
hilarious yeah and always very much to
this day yeah I mean yeah yes hilarious
yeah yeah very funny and he so he was
always supportive with me I think that
when I was like I think I want to go do
comedy and Texas
yeah like sure sure that I'd like to do
that too yeah you're you're a child so
you can do that so was that what was
that the next move after no and I used
to snowboard a lot I was like I would
take I went to college in Missoula and
I'd take every winter semester off
because it it doesn't really snow in
Montana yeah you know cuz of Al Gore
because of Al Gore and his invention
that's invented via a warmer so we would
go my cousin and good best friend didn't
realize we were cousins still later i
real
that sounds very Montana banjo music
playing I just I was man or woman he was
a man he's a man okay that makes it yeah
yeah he's a pro professional snowboarder
sure and even in high school he was like
going off on trips and so he was gifted
at it I started with him I wasn't as
gifted sure I would follow him enough
you my other friend Germany the whole
live in Benton Oregon and living house
together and that was my first living
outside of because even through college
I lived in my dad's basement okay I
would take winter semester off make up
for it in the summer okay
and yeah so winters were celebrated oh
yeah for me it's growing up in Michigan
it was like summer summer summer and
when I went for the first time I
couldn't believe people were like let's
get through this summer we got I got to
get healthy for ski season and I was
like this is [ __ ] nuts I got that is
when I was in shape as during the winter
hiking building jumps going to
gymnastics learning to flip around
trying to do those flips right um wow
it's really getting into it and like my
mid-20s yeah which it's late everything
with snowboard you're done when you're
like 23 just because physical it's it's
too hard yeah an injuries which I that's
kind of where that story's going they
take oh [ __ ] yeah most most really
physically demanding sports your window
like you peak at 25 I mean tennis it's
like oh he's coming into the twilight of
his career he's 28 and a half and it's
like Jesus Christ yeah that's what I
want to get into I've started swimming I
think there's no ceiling on that and
swimming I just start I judge I have a
snorkel oh wow in with a freestyle snow
I call it goes up the middle I've never
seen that I have put low flippers on my
feet that you can hardly notice yeah I
swam today I wouldn't guys swam after
that where do you swim 24-hour fitness
yeah that's a gross pool yeah it's the
only reason I feel comfortable saying
that there's a toilet paper in it is
because my pool is grosser than that
poor LA Fitness 24-hour fitness but
breathing wood wood is the was the worst
part and you've just solved that yeah
yeah I looked it up and like do they
make snow and I went to the Swim Shop
and sure and I said people use these to
ink
start lung capacity because you can put
a cap on it and admit this you're not
cool if you don't have a cap on it so I
put the cap on top but I cut the hole in
it to where I still can breathe so so
that that would then limit how much no
you're not this I don't want to be
judged by the older men who are swimming
next to me and they're like oh he's got
a cap on his snoring this is freestyle
is it is it mostly age angry Asian
people in the pool there because that's
what LA Fitness I don't care I talk to
you if they're next to me I'm like we're
talking does a snorkel look dumb they're
like no whatever helps look I would love
a picture of you in full Russian
swimming we're going it's yeah I had a
nose plug for a while goggles on top of
that why don't you just look I'm down
with this do your thing I and everything
about you see because I drink and choke
water okay for one you do if you if you
just matter at it now
okay but I never learned how to swim I
had to learn how to swim once my hip
doctor is like you can't run anymore you
can swim so I was like I don't know how
so I went with a kickboard I learned
yep just learned you learned and now I
like it a lot it's great I'm fast I bet
you're saying that you're so fast okay
you're not as fast as most of these
older ladies so what were your
birthday's like yeah drink it's it was a
lot of being indoors yup and drinking
yeah
the Montana there's a lot to drink what
when did you start drinking and as in
Michigan hasn't much during the
wintertime yeah it's a balance of
gaining weight because you're drinking
40s at night out of boredom yeah but
during the day we were hiking and
snowboarding what what what what type of
age was alcohol first around I didn't
start really drinking till after her
height in college like I was scared of
it I thought yeah I thought sex and
drinking were things that were gonna
kill me I don't know why eyes paranoid
yeah so then when I did discover I'm
like my freshman year of college those
two things
yeah I was a bit of an animal sure yeah
and you could even do both of them at
the same time Oh everyone's fun I have a
bottle in the mouth
my dick in the lady come on that's
nowhere that's was supposed to go that's
not what this is all about
no better than having a lady in the
mouth and dick okay so a lot of drinking
is going on birthday time February 5th
my yeah I there was a time in my there's
a birthday that was terrible let's just
do it well that's what I that's what
we're getting yeah yeah I don't know
gone a bit good is my 21st birthday that
I went snowboarding and something
happened where they're at the top of
Mount Bachelor Mount Bachelor it is a
volcano cartoonishly there's a cone up
like where it has erupted it is active
view as we traversed from the top of the
chair to this place where you're out of
bounds what city is this Bend Oregon
Bend org it's a beautiful go I've heard
of the awful people train the right
bikes there people train to be MMA
fighters there you're high up right it's
beautiful and it's not quite a resort
well now it probably is I heard what
they're for you know since 99 well look
it up look up Mount Bachelor Bend Oregon
yeah it's it's a beautiful place
but this was my yeah it was my first
birthday away from home it was yeah we
were I went off this jump there's like
steam shooting out of the snow like you
can fall right active yeah and you have
to pull your friends out and it'll just
be an open room of steam and there's the
snow this and there's chair lifts that
that companies that take you up to this
Dante's Inferno yes yes I feel like it
is legal I feel like one must signed a
pretty thick waiver for this you are
well that's why I learned you're
forfeiting the right to get picked up by
safety people I skate Patrol if you're
out of bounds I didn't know that okay so
I there we jumped off I was heading
toward there's a cornice and they used
to like you'd hear it at night they
would avalanche it to preemptively I
heard from avalanching during the day so
it was the funny thing yeah
yeah they keep it from avalanche by
avalanching yeah it's a lot like
chemotherapy first we're gonna pump you
enhancer whoops didn't work you've
cancer so that's kind of what happen
here I was going towards the jmo gentler
near the JMO Jays famous jump for the
five of you that know yeah and this
other guy was going at the same time and
so we are kind of heading towards the
same spot I realized as I as composed
snowboarding yeah and so I'm started
going too fast because you know everyone
I want to beat him I mean so I've
launched off this thing going incredibly
fast this is your birthday this is on my
birthday well and it might be the day
before okay but it's it's I was on I
asked you what's your worst birthday
this memory came in together this is
because it all leads up to the worst
moment you have a birthday ever so I
went off and I landed on what I guess
had fallen from the mountain as I am
latched I want to describe as a
volkswagen sized piece of ice that was
snow was blown over it so I couldn't see
it right so I went I wrote a little ways
after that going very fast and hit this
thing and so you landed the jump I think
I may be but check to okay I was out it
was it was a lot of air as they had you
been drinking yeah I was not drunk okay
that's good to know by ice to head over
ice starfish my my board my foot the
binding ripped out of the blah port on
the front Wow all the inserts like it
just ripped out of your of so I'm star
fishing with a full snowboard on what's
a starfish it's when your thoughts when
you're yeah if you imagine I've also
heard the term character from Sponge Bob
I've also heard of women's star fishing
in bed Oh women just right lay there and
this you [ __ ] them this is a little more
active and less lucky for anyone so I
was just rolling down the hill out
starfish knees bent backwards broke my
ankle broke oh [ __ ]
think I messed up my nose even my
goggles just cut my feet like they broke
and everything flew off one of my boots
flew off a snowboarding boo
no no it was no I had the boot and
binding that's why was boot and binding
still on one foot and the entire
snowboard on the other foot so that so
but one of the bindings ripped off the
[ __ ] snow yeah and I find a thing I
was out for a little bit and then yeah
and I heard the guy was that I cut off
called me a kook like this for my 80s
sir oh that's really nice
oh yeah I was I tried to find him later
yeah I mean [ __ ] you buddy
yeah he he could have been dead and he's
happy he's healthy enough they actually
prepared you for comedy I could have
been dead and someone still hates Mike
yeah yeah you could have helped you
instead he called you a [ __ ] I clearly
lost and he still didn't want me to win
and I couldn't they weren't coming to
get me my friends knew it was bad and so
they went to get Ski Patrol and I had to
crawl out of the top of this volcano I'm
in the bottom and the volcano also the
whole time it's like I don't want to die
this way and have the volcano erupt
what if that yeah if I was injured and
then also on top of it yeah that would
be the worst birthday yeah I'm just
being held up by a geyser of lava on a
ever-shrinking piece of ice what are you
a glove or a remittance omitting guy
yeah yeah why either warmer gloves
because they keep your fingers together
I've never had a successful pair of
gloves maybe if you pay a lot of money
but your individual phalanges just gotta
have them all together for warmth yeah
you gotta be able to make fists mm-hmm
so yeah I'm a gloves man no good but -
no mittens band but gloves you know it's
easier to put on the binding you know
they're just give and take or just give
and take whatever those decisions you
gotta make in life ah so I've yeah I had
big swollen knees and I was like I blew
out my knees that's what has happened
here Wow right and the ankles broken I
didn't know that yeah and thumb is broke
oh yeah mice I still have this little
weird thumb that looks weird
yes left his left thumb looks weirdly it
doesn't bend back oh and that's from
this yeah yeah it was that I just messed
up my body
yeah and that fall it was very bad and
but then realized when I went to the
doctor I didn't blow out my knees they
just got swung they did bend back
but they were fine but yeah when did you
go to the dot so Ski Patrol comes I
crawled out of there crawled to the to
the chairlift and it took it down yeah
and no one was at the mountain anymore
and I'm like hey guys thanks for picking
where's our [ __ ] friends uh you know
yeah okay I'm not in touch with a lot of
them anymore touch with them I mean that
sounds like they said maybe like hey
that guy's hurt down there and then they
went down and they just kind of figured
you would figure prospected to me when I
crawled over to them there oh yeah we're
just gonna go get you man oh Jesus and
and so our lift down is kind of
insulting to get someone my birthday I
just yeah it is
everyone's looking at ya so I did just
yeah I I got hurt yeah hey I got her it
was pretty gnarly yeah so I was at that
night it was the worst birthday ever too
because I couldn't but because my thumb
was messed up I couldn't really use the
crutches I should add a wheelchair so
you went straight to the doctor yeah and
on the mountain or is it like this Bend
is is is it is there a guy that like
works the I mean I don't know if you
like night injured everyday at a ski
result irat had the one here the mammoth
and yeah it was like a hospital there's
a doctor there his [ __ ] it was all of
moms who had ran in a snowboard with a
broken wrist yeah that's like a view
every snowboard yes do not fall back and
put your arms behind you you will break
your wrist and I saw 15 ladies it was
the talk take it on the shoulder what do
you do cuz I've always Wahlberg flopped
yeah with everything you know I'm
falling I put my hands by my sides and I
give most of it to what I've always
always had a nice layer back fat yes
nice job yeah yeah yeah I've never been
I've got one of my knee one of my first
time snowboarding was that mammoth an it
was an icy day and man do you fall a lot
if you're new yeah if you're new you
fall and you fall unexpectedly yeah
that's that edge it takes you a while to
figure out and if you haven't skied
especially yes that you cannot be on the
edge that is closest to the body heading
down the mountain yes yeah up mountain
edge at all times but down that that
turning were you
turn in is a very frightening thing yeah
yeah anything because there's a moment
there where you're flat based and he
does if you don't you will be thrown I'm
a very bad snowboarder I'm a much better
skier but I'd love the feeling of
snowboarding I love and snowboarding
when you turn you actually can touch the
mountain mm-hmm which is such an amazing
feeling and it's probably how surfers
feel I don't know about surfing
I loved skiing when I was young but I
never liked to have him poles I didn't
get it
yeah if you're a good scare you know the
poles they they're useful yeah but I
just mind flopped around and potentially
would stab me face yeah yes I just liked
I wanted a snowboard get rid of these
poles so you're at this doctor whoever
it is he says your knees are okay yeah
yeah and well swollen you have to wait
till they're not swollen I can I don't
know I don't think I I think I was like
how much is an x-ray I think my knees
are fine
yeah that's ankle I've done I bred
broken political but that ain't left
ankle I knew what the boot was off yeah
but I also did something to my tell vit
like after yeah yeah I hope this isn't
getting boring but there's I Mitch
there's certain things one of the basic
things that you should be able to do and
do well is called a method it's like a
backside air you grab behind your heel
and go you out stretch your back leg and
it style-wise it is the the perfect
looking thing on a snowboard in my
opinion I've seen I've seen this on X
Games yeah like in the halfpipe when
they go huge and they they tuck the
board in and stick the bag there's a lot
of versions of that one after this
accident even when I healed I couldn't
reach back there anymore
and now I can't do it I can't touch that
shoe I have to tie my shoe weird I have
to go from the inside G's and I had to
get my hip replaced life to you and I
didn't I do that I think it's from that
accent he said no you just have bad
bones but I think early on I did
something in my hip because I remember
after that not being the same yeah so I
think I did something to my hip I mean
this is look I'm 36 now and I if I work
out like two days in a row my left calf
decides to explode
and this is because when I was 20 or 21
I wasn't doing the same sport you were
but I was running the body into the
ground doing tennis yeah doing tennis
and it was like doing takeaway I do
tennis now we play match
log you do but at the time is it's like
running a car as hard as it can like it
can take it it's just five years later
it's it's not gonna be like my dad was
constantly warning me it's like lamb
once you're 40 yeah it's gonna hit yeah
yeah and he is exactly what's exactly
right yeah so I'm gonna get a little cap
on my hip well Grayson the hip the full
hip replacement is a very common thing
and it's people love it I have only
heard good thing and that's what this
podcast is is a hip replacement podcast
yeah everybody's tough to book but we do
get so when do you start drinking
because when you're an injured and
you're in a ski town I feel you're not
supposed to I was I was icing but yeah I
also was just drinking that's why I'm
paying my 21st like your 21st birthday
you're supposed to be it's supposed to
be fun and I'm in a town that doesn't
even have any options there's a one bar
called the evil sister that we would go
to okay and and it's so I just sat em
drink of 40 and watched Fletch by myself
that's right that's what you told me my
first birthday that was just the I was I
liked Fletch I like that it's a good
movie but when you just turned 21 and
you're just having a first legal moniker
yeah and it should always be legal but
um why so so so boring look I I like you
I would consider you a friend you seem
like a nice person you seem like you
have friends where thank your friends on
your 21st birthday that's this I they
were maybe they were sitting there with
me but that's not the memory you have
they were all seemed they all had dates
with girls that night probably just to
make it worse okay I'll be like they all
fell in love that night and I quickly
realized there's I need to go move back
to Montana and not be here so I got on a
bus all with my crutches and left my
stuff up during this injury yeah yeah
so that injury made you kind of realize
like I need to be closer to home type
thing it was that was that what a while
I guess no I went back up there the next
winter
okay I did it again like every winter I
would live in Bend but it was it took me
a long time to heal not that bad though
it was just like you're when you're
young you're just like yeah I'm kind of
sore my ankle geralt and it makes funny
noises now but that's exactly yeah yeah
yeah I'll just wear noise-cancelling
headphones they didn't exist yet what
what did it do to you what did the
injury do to you like mentally did you
back off a little bit of the Jamo jumped
method kickflip anything that jmo jump
Chris Jameson tech professional okay it
no actually when eyes younger a broken
ankle would make me anxious and yearn to
be healthy again so I could show right
you could gender the [ __ ] volcano so
if anything after that I think I
progressed for a couple years so it
drove you to like be maybe maybe not
taking risks like I'm gonna leap off
this giant yeah I see cornice thing
maybe less of that but no more paying
attention to just trying to learn tricks
and maybe I was going a little smaller
off of things if that other guy who
called you a kook if he on your 21st
birthday before you broke your thumb
maybe both knees left hip and left ankle
and snowboard bindings if he wasn't
there do you think that wouldn't have
happened you would have hit that jump
because you didn't feel absolutely when
it would not have happened yeah cuz so
he's the cook
I wouldn't yeah yeah and I was really
mad at him I did blame him I'm realizing
now I played but I was talking [ __ ]
about him he was a easily recognizable
guy because he would basically were this
motocross type out all these logos all
over his legs yeah yeah was this about
twenty years ago it was a bad way okay
and you still remember what outfit he
was wearing yeah yeah that's all the
fishpaw he was like a fish pause sponsor
guy I don't even think they make stuff
anymore no offense to fish pile you're
nice bunch of boys I think the boys in
house that's where their right names
right anyway I did see him at a party
when I and my buddy
Aaron Aaron who later Aaron became he'd
start jackass Aaron Magee he wasn't it
is a big listener yeah yeah yeah yeah
but he was like he was we were at a
party and that guy was there and he's
like that's the guy are you gonna talk
to him and I'm like that you have
crutches yeah I gonna do
and the guy knew I have talking [ __ ]
about him but he knew eyes and crutches
so nothing really happened there but
then okay let's just jump to another
dissapoint Aaron this guy that was this
wait is this a know disappointing
birthday this was not my birthday
yeah I'm let's just say it was I was on
a road trip it was midsummer but I saw
him in Portland and he is working at
some skate shop the same [ __ ] guy
Aaron yeah from Bend
okay he's like well it's still in Oregon
but I was on a skate trip with buddies
we were going to skate parks and it used
to be all I did yeah yeah yeah I wasn't
even that good at it I was okay my
friend did say it was good anyway he was
asked he was at working at this skate
shop and he had a shirt that said
jackass on it like an iron-on puffy yeah
and he had he's like you do comedy now I
think I just started doing comedy and he
knew that and he said I'm I'm sold at
show to MTV and all these huge Spike
Jonze is all these all these all the
guys involved for that we're not yet
involved he just said Spike Jonze on him
we're making some show and and he was
like will you help me I have to come up
with ideas we're gonna take kayaks and
we're gonna drop in at Burnside and
these boats know why that sounds
dangerous I let it was right like it
would list all these stunts basically
and I was like that's not really is it
funny I don't like I'm on a trip with my
friends I can't really and to this day
all my friends are like that guy asked
you to be a member on floor of Jack a
member when you were asked to invest in
Apple yeah you've said no thank you
who's gonna use a personal computer yeah
and and then later in life I'm just
interviewing Aaron on a because any kind
of ignored me yeah yeah what what what
sold this jackass to MTV
like it was it was it like a little
five-minute
thing was it a pitch in the room it was
based on there's a magazine called Big
Brother that was a skate magazine that
later was published by Flint
but before Flint it was actually a man
it would have skate boring in it but
then just a page of like hey guys here's
underage girls boobs girls your age and
there'd be and then there's articles how
to kill yourself
make sure to slit your wrists vertically
otherwise you don't mean and there's
like illustrations like it was a comedy
magazine it was big magazine called the
Big Brother Wow and they would put out
skate videos and in the skate videos
these guys like johnny Knoxville would
shoot himself in the chest with a
wearing a ball proof vest
steve-o would back flip over something
well my buddy Ryan I laid over him and
there was like some skate based stunts
but it was funny just intense intense
yeah yeah wee man would run around in a
diaper all the guys that became jackass
were in these big brother skate videos
so I think yeah dick house or Jeff
Tremaine the guy that who's a big
producer guy now
he just took those videos and he's like
hey MTV what we did and the smartest
thing they ever did was name a jackass
because it's like that's what every
older person says don't be a jackass
they're being it and it was like it just
nailed it yeah it's almost like if it
was called like I bet you can't do this
or say let's do it like it would never
this is perfect but if you call jackass
even a grandpa will be like well they're
being Jerrica go ahead and keep watchin
even at the beginning there's a
disclaimer hey don't be a jackass
I love the professionals and everyone
has a disclaimer now in their show and
they were the first I could have been
one of them but they all have trouble
walking hi guys and I also heard that
maybe some of them are on dialysis a lot
yeah they're there in some of the
outtakes of those probably stunts are
not at all funny all those guys have
been critically injured this is true
we're not [ __ ] around I know like III
don't want to say names cuz I don't know
but there's some there are some that are
on dialysis consistently now because
they've taken such hits to real major
organs in their body
I mean I just said Shan Shan Moss here
we were both have his have a good trip
we do welding them and he wouldn't tell
me how to actually make a pipe bomb on
the air and I thought that was probably
a good decision but here I am not
dealing hype bom-bom-bom a but he used
to blow up [ __ ] all the time as a kid
one of his worst birthdays was he got
caught blowing up 15 mailboxes in his
hometown you know that your your
birthday story isn't that good when you
have to go tell old birthday stories I
love no no I'm just weak kid this is a
this is what I love about this podcast
it is everyone's story is unique to them
and did anybody sing you happy birthday
that day do you think now you know what
that's about 21st I don't like the
obligation of having to sing that song
yeah and equally whoever's it's being
sung to they don't like it being sung to
them know what am i all agree everyone
sings it while they're rolling their
eyes yeah I I really like this this is
like when someone told me once that we
have to stop eating turkey on
Thanksgiving because nobody likes Turkey
and I was like holy [ __ ] you're right I
don't think anyone likes Turkey and
you're right about this no one likes
singing it and you certainly don't like
sitting there hearing it no no I love
having people around me that love and
care about me if that's not what you
said you know that the song the song
yeah that's the only that's the bad part
of everyone's birthday yeah was the
thoughts I it's terrible what did you do
last February now we have more right I
think it used to be illegal to sing like
in movies now it's like now I never mind
no go ahead and sing you're allowed to
you're allowed to sing it now and people
were paying [ __ ] royalties for like
50 years that song was owned by Warner
Brothers it was there was a long story
in The New York Times about it and it
was it was suspect about who owned it
and and they kind of finagled their way
into it and typical Warner Brothers if
you know anything about the Warner
Brothers sketchy dudes that's too good
what did you do this last February 5th
do you do things now for your birthday I
don't I feel real lame but I I will
they're not kid no one's gonna believe
me but I have forgotten my birthday for
a portion of the days and then realized
midday as like oh no it's not it's today
it's not in a couple days yeah it's
today I don't plan anything I've always
but secretly like I'm trying to be a
cowboy about my birthday I'm a grown-up
I don't need to write but I would once
just for once I'd like that people hide
and jump out and yell surprise that's
never happened to me in my life you've
always wanted a surprise birthday yeah
no I don't think I'll ever get it I
think I'm getting in the age now where
you don't want to jump out and scare me
well you certainly don't want to sing
you happy birthday
no but that'll make my heart explode I
mean that's that are they heart attack
kicks in uh significant this is what
significant others do they plan their
significant others birthdays so I had
sweet girlfriends in the past that have
planned planned things right but you've
never had a surprise no no do you know
that a that I've I had to categorize
each worse birthday in this show the
highest percentage of worse birthdays
his surprise parties thrown people don't
want surprise parties thrown for them
and it's fastened and it's always like
the newer girlfriend that doesn't really
that someone thinks they don't have the
authority to do that yet or it always
just draws up all this [ __ ] people like
being control of their lives and they
don't like a surprise party you want I
kind of surprise I think the things that
I'm not thinking of is it's going to be
a bunch of people in the room together
that you aren't deciding on you're not
excited to be based on your facebook or
something like it's also oh I invited
yeah two of my ex-girlfriends to your
Instagram and then also those two guys
last time they're together they punched
each other this is not gonna be and why
are we at the Opera or wherever like
it's also a surprise what day it is
where it is like yeah I guess what you
want is honey here's where and who's the
the list and I want it to be a surprise
party one of the best surprise party
stories I ever heard it was my I think
it was my high school math teacher
through his wife a surprise
party at a restaurant they go to the
restaurant to eat surprise there's like
ten people there oh great
you know bobasa to do the dinner little
nice long dinner whatever alright time
to go home
they go home surprised bigger surprise
party oh wow now there's family there
now there's bigger friends that to me
that that's a some badass [ __ ] yeah
that's some badass
there was one time I was involved with
surprising Matt Braunger and it's his
girlfriend like her rock she's like ah
she created like an annoying reason
maybe that they had to go back to his
apartment I like this and I gotta get
tampons or whatever yeah yeah and he was
like they maybe ever even arguing but
you could see them come up and I had my
the needle on the held above the record
and everyone was actually hiding and rut
like it was an explode maybe it was too
loud and we all yelled and it scared the
hell out of him but he was it was a true
surprise he was overjoyed yeah yeah it's
okay it's fun you know ladies you hear
that out there someone used to throw
Chris Fairbanks a surprise birthday
party one where he hasn't broken
numerous bones
you still snowboard um I can i when I go
it this I have trouble putting my bite
that's front binding on like it that's
why I realized over the last and I live
here and I don't know anyone really that
does it as often as me I thought was a
skier friend you were probably a very
good snowboarder I won't I'm a I'm kind
of I don't want to wait for people I'm
like I'm like fine I get it a long time
I had a great time when I go back home I
ride with my friends you know in Montana
yep and that's enough for me I kind of
don't
oddly I don't miss it because there
isn't a reminder sure of any season here
in LA and there's just a reminder of
brightness and yet dryness yeah do you
surf I need that's another thing I
cannot do right now like I thought about
it and I got on my board I have a couple
surfboards but I'm not the best surfer
okay and do you have health care I do oh
yeah yeah and ice sag stuff that's good
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's nice a lot of
lot of comics don't have health care and
it determines a lot of our life
decisions I feel like when I get
have done I will be able to get up that
the act of standing sideways with my
left foot forward you know I'm regular
footed and getting up on my hands with
that my left leg in front of me it's
just sitting like this nothing that's
that's fine hurts so leaning down and
getting I can't get up on a surfboard I
would have to have someone tow me in
which would be a jetski that Spencer
that's something that Dan Bilzerian does
he's got he's got military assault
rifles helicopters pays prostitute or
girl whatever he's a millionaire with
yachts
but then he was on the show and he kind
of he was made fun of himself I want to
get him on this podcast but he his
comments are the best
I mean he'll he'll post like him
shooting drones down with a machine gun
with like tits flying all over the place
and then it would be 2,000 comments the
first one will be like this is the most
amazing thing ever the next one is like
die in hell you rotten Pig the next one
is like the love Danby and the next ones
like what who raised this [ __ ] wolf
you know it's like it's really split
serious room he's like a walking
politics he was he wasn't he was a
wonderful he was a wonderful guest and
he was a lot more humble than we all get
it and thank you dan Bilzerian for being
a now failed comedy show gone Thank You
Mikhail you know Joel McHale [ __ ] it
up Fairbanks thank you for sharing your
worst birthday I'm sorry that happened
to you oh that's right but selfishly I'm
happy to hear that your worst birthday
still affects you physically it's like
true injury [ __ ] where can people find
all of your information besides
hopefully a second season of almost
genius on truTV well hopefully hopefully
there will be another that we haven't
heard anything bad yet okay good just
softly to quit talking good to now adays
they don't actually calm they're like
hey you're done just wanted to let you
know yeah what do that they might have
void Khan you think they just don't tie
up the boat and it just kind of slowly
drifts yeah yeah you never see what
banging
hanging what's your I don't know why
there was a dinghy what what are you
promoting now nautical nautical terms
and this shirt I heard it's great yeah
we'll actually get a picture of thanks I
went boating the other day and I had to
get a boating shirt I'm uh yeah that's
go to my website Chris Fairbanks calm
this is great funny videos on out
there's some yeah yeah as some how to
town dates there okay
what's this hat bacon around town I just
just as part of my name on it so I banks
is a surf where company got it okay and
and around here in LA where do you
perform most I like going really improv
like the old improv lab that's fun you
know it's not like I'm deciding not to
do the main room I'd like sheriff I've
been there but I've been doing a lab
more just because it's easier to work on
my specific art there there's more
things there yeah that seem like more
opportunities that's the reason that's
not because I'm not loved
well the main room it's always like
special guest I'll just [ __ ] say Dane
Cook just say just say it which version
of his arms
what's Nate or his arms gonna be and
she's ripped right now someone I was I
was I fought I always follow him they
always [ __ ] put me up after him and
it's two different women at the improv
photographed him on stage with this
giant Dane Cook like and then tagged me
in it so I come home from the improv I'm
already mad glad to watch him for 85
minutes and then I see oh I got some
tags on my Instagram it's just them
photographing Dane Cook tagging me but
luckily then looked at the list and like
oh it's a tag but that other guy in
there he'll appreciate being in being I
mentioned with Dane I wrote and I said
don't why did you do this to me I was as
if I was done wrong ladies and gentleman
this is Chris Fairbanks
February 5th what do you want Erin what
oh yeah yeah Chris sorry
yeah thank you I don't do that enough
he's doing that for me thanks buddy did
that glitter threaten us Chris Fairbanks
what is your podcast it's called do you
need a ride we
right now I heard about this yeah it
used to be in a car but we were gonna
kill someone so we now do it in the
studio it sounds better okay
thanks Darren and yeah it's a better who
who else you do Karen kill Gareth oh
yeah sure and you guys would talk about
originally we picked up comics at the
airport brought them tour from tour from
the airport and recorded in the car but
it was really hard for me to record and
yeah I've heard someone we were gonna
get in a car wreck well in what's nice
is everyone enjoyable to do everyone
wants a [ __ ] ride to the airport yeah
that it would be good I like that okay
so please check out that's on the all
things comedy network yes you always
make me laugh thank you for sharing your
story thank you for sharing it is one of
a kind and ladies and gentlemen this is
Chris Fairbanks that's Chris Fairbanks
ladies and gentlemen this is the first
outro I've done for the show where the
guest has actually stayed in the room
for the outro so this is this is gonna
be a little bit still history very very
funny man please check out his stand-up
go to Chris Fairbanks calm for his live
dates or he just told me his Twitter
handle is Chris Fairbanks at Twitter
which is definitely not his Twitter
handle his Twitter handle has at Chris
Fairbanks I think he brought up some
great points especially about the Happy
Birthday song man it's just nice to have
somebody say say it it's tough having
people singing that song it's tough
having to sing the song I love that his
worst birthday truly affects his life to
this day physically and I want you guys
to know as listeners when I asked him if
did he come back you know a little more
protective snowboarding he said no but
as I said yes Aaron his eyes said yes I
mean come on how do you not have that
type of injury and fall and knock and
not think about it every time I want to
say something to the guy that was gonna
go off the jump also that called Chris a
kook I think you're a bad person it's
possible that you've already are already
dead it's been 20 years at this time but
I think you're a bad person I think you
heard him physic
and emotionally Aaron tell me about Big
Brother magazine Big Brother magazine
was a skateboarding magazine found by
Steve Rocco in 1992 hmm
it ceased production in 2004 okay no
subject was taboo they talked about suit
how to commit suicide okay how to make a
fake ID love it so almost like a edgy
mad mad magazine yeah mad would you tell
you how to commit suicide but that's
cool and then it was and then eventually
it was purchased by Larry Flynt's
company yeah is this correct well okay
I'm looking forward to looking that up
1997 97 Larry fence company bought it
maybe you had something to do or
arguably did start jackass yeah
absolutely that's Chris Fairbanks you
guys I'm Michael Kosta this is the worst
birthday podcast new episodes every
Thursday please tweet to me at Michael
Kosta email me Michael at Michael Kosta
comm tell me what you think about the
podcast if you leave a rating and review
on iTunes I'll come over to your house
and I'll suck your dad's dick okay
everyone wants that to happen for their
father
it just goes a long way we appreciate
that and use the hash tag worst bday pod
and you can keep track everyone else
that listens to the silly little podcast
we have I'm Michael Kosta this is the
all things comedy Network and the worst
birthday podcast thanks for listening